pero por el momento se tiene muy pocos
detalles mientras el gobierno argentino
anuncia el acuerdo
desde el fondo monetario se dice que se
llegó a un principio de entendimiento a
entendimientos básicos así que no
tenemos mucho detalles salvo que el
presidente fernández anunció que no
habrá de mayores ajustes que no habrá
reformas estructurales antipáticas así
que es como que él por lo menos por el
momento tenemos bastante poca
información sobre los detalles del
acuerdo lo que sí es bueno
les gustó digamos decir que llega en un
momento bueno para argentina porque
adelante fue con el organismo no era no
era lo que más nos convenía pero todavía
está ausente saber si vamos a tener el
programa que necesitamos para salir de
la inflación y la falta de crecimiento
ahora la gente en las calles exige el no
pago de esa deuda creo que esta
negociación realizada por el ejecutivo
podría lograr calmar a la opinión
pública
yo diría que hay una parte de la
sociedad argentina que se ve con cierto
grado de poesía digamos revolucionaria
el no pago al fondo pero yo creo que la
gran mayoría de los argentinos estamos
de acuerdo con que hay que honrar las
deudas hay que hablar los compromisos
asumidos sería bastante duro e nefasto
para argentina no pagar y caer
nuevamente en default con el fondo este
acuerdo anunciado hoy justo se produce
al momento que vence un pago con el
fondo que argentina dudaba de hacer
porque no entiende hacer si no había un
acuerdo así que viabiliza ese pago
evitamos el default y eso siempre es una
un anuncio positivo lo que ellos trato
de diferenciar es que la mayoría es
argentina también quiere un programa
económico que ayude a salir de la crisis
y por ahora ese programa económico no
conocemos los detalles y tampoco sabemos
si existe
aún está sobre la mesa la posibilidad de
que el país se niegue a pagar esta deuda
el gobierno ha dicho que pagará solo lo
que pueda qué consecuencias tendría ello
por ejemplo
en ayudas por ahora creo que el anuncio
de hoy es un progreso precisamente por
eso porque se ratificó la voluntad de
pagar de hecho hoy se paga se va a pagar
la semana que viene a otro vencimiento
al fondo y después se recuperaría ese
esos desembolsos dentro del marco de un
nuevo programa que se esbozó durante el
día de hoy no pagar obviamente tiene
consecuencias muy serias que ya la
estábamos sufriendo porque como estaba
esta especulación en la calle de que no
se va a pagar tuvimos un gran salto
enorme de la cotización
informal en los mercados informales del
dólar no hacia el oficial o sea una
corrida importante de mucha gente que
decidió proteger sus ahorros comprando
dólares y también tuvimos un aumento
enorme de la prima de riesgo que para
argentina por su deuda caída de las de
todos los activos de riad argentinas
acciones y bonos todos hasta ayer a la
noche hoy con el anuncio mejoró de nuevo
tampoco las perspectivas de que no vamos
a caer en ese default así quieren se nos
hubiera hecho mucho más difícil seguir
accediendo a los mercados de deuda al
financiamiento internacional tanto para
el sector público pero sobre todo el
sector privado que es lo que interesa
desde el punto de vista del crecimiento
futuro de la argentina
señor luís seco economista y director
del sitio web perspectivas económicas
muchas gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
france 24